Five four,
three,
two law and with luck,
dude,
a bright to the dark side.
Now you plan quick.
I got my ass whooped.
Yeah.
Well you were in a fucking melee.
There's three other dudes
and they're blasting.
It's a one on one map that maps chaos.
It's so fun though.
How Fun is that Shit?
It reminds me of golden eye.
Did you ever get into that?
How dare you?
First of all,
64 that's a great game.
That check came can suck all the dicks.
You using those stupid x-box things
lets you control the mouse and keyboard.
It's where you're at.
That's why you get fucked up.
You don't even know how to move.
It was hard for me to move back and
forth if it was the controller at game on
what?
Yeah,
yeah cause nobody can move.
Nobody can move.
Then you're all right with
control this and did that.
Fucking that game's chaos.
Jamie and I've been going back and
forth for fucking four or five days now.
You'd be surprised.
There are a couple of
guys that can compete.
A few that can compete with
the mouse and keyboard.
I wouldn't be surprised.
I'm sure they can,
but they have zero life.
They don't even know
what a pussy looks like.
Old School quakes.
Old Score,
right?
Yeah.
Cool.
We're on quick for this quake
champions that you play on line.
We've been playing quake for,
because we could set it up on
what's called a local area network,
a lan,
and it's real easy and there's no latency.
It's just direct from
computer to computer.
It's fun to just thinking of the one guy,
he said he's really
aggressive workout dude.
What's that?
The guy that I'm thinking of,
he's a,
he's a video video can play a very good,
he's really good.
He hasn't named Nick Marks.
I'm only taking,
I'm sure he gets pissy.
There's some good looking dude.
Yeah,
I'm sure there are.
I'm sure there are,
but it's not fun to say no.
It's fun to say that
they weighed four pounds.
You'd like to picture of Miss Jess.
Yeah,
and they can't find their deck,
but now those kids make
money.
Here's even hot chicks
who play video games.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's a good move for hot chick.
Like there's,
there's hot chicks that hunt because
like in they wear makeup and shit,
full eyelashes and shed because
it brings them into that world.
And then all the guys were good.
You look at hers,
she loves went.
Oh look.
Yeah.
It was like stand in front of like a
endangered species with their tits out.
Like there's hot girls
to take Moitai class.
Right.
And they get all serious angry face.
Don't talk to anybody.
Pretend they're real fighters.
Some of them are real.
Yeah,
but let,
some of them are not though.
Some of them get super serious.
That's when I whisper like this.
Yeah.
When they say,
I don't like when people say I'm going,
I'm on a train today.
I'm like,
well what are you doing?
He'd taken [inaudible] training.
That's not training.
We trained for what we'll your training
for the top clubs are be training for
some deck.
Ah,
his God damn games.
They're so addictive.
You word like straight
up addicted to them,
right?
Oh yeah.
I had a real problem.
Well,
I kind of got a little
bit of a problem now.
Jamie and I have been
talking back and forth.
He's up on me a little bit too.
That's why I have to kick Jeff out every
now and then just so Jamie and I go one
on one,
one on one.
Last time I fucked him up and he hit.
He quit cause me and Jeffrey he pray.
Right like you can just
not easy prey anymore.
Jeff was easy prey for a little bit.
If I want all these games.
How long do you think we'd
be here playing quick.
True.
You want to get you one,
all these keys to competitor you would
you say and you lost 13 to five because
you were trying real hard.
You got fucked up son.
I let you up and talking to change.
You were talking,
you said take and he says,
yeah,
sure.
Fucked him up.
The problem with having another person
in the thing is he always goes after Jeff
first.
He said,
easy kill.
That's what I mean.
He comes and gets me.
I couldn't really get my fucking be
quite yes are killing me right away.
No.
Jeff starting to win.
He came real close to when that last
one because he had the same old.
We're not a lot.
He's definitely should
be playing right now.
It'd be smart.
Well I told him to
fucking lift weights too.
I'm like,
dude,
you kind of this whole gym
here while shows going on.
Watch the security camera.
Get your pump on.
Just get checked.
So he could call out there.
So let's talk about these fights,
bro.
First of all,
let's start with Diego
motherfucking Sanchez.
All these young guns sleeping on
Diego Sanchez fully redeemed himself.
Do not sleep.
Do not.
Just do not,
just don't cause he will fuck.
Ugh.
People up still.
How about Micky Gall bid
and did you see that?
I saw this.
As you see there's a
video of him bite him.
Well there's a video of Diego.
Go and look at this shit.
Yeah,
Diego,
I saw on his Instagram he showed his
chest where he does a bit that it's crazy.
I thought they said Micky
Gall had a hard cut,
like a really hard cut.
And maybe that's one of the
reasons he got so tired.
I just don't think that so far.
He's just,
the skills aren't there yet.
No.
He was out of his element a little bit.
Well,
I gave you outclass Diego is a monster.
I mean,
you're dealing with a guy who has 40.
Look at that bite mark.
That is,
that is crazy.
Bite the fuck Micky Gall.
All bytes guys had been guys before.
You can't be on my team.
Yeah,
you're off the team.
It's not good.
It's bad luck.
[inaudible] Diego didn't
say shit to the referee.
Just kept smashed.
Dude.
He is such a savage and he's a sandwiches
they getting since he was four years
old in the USA,
he won ultimate fighter season one,
2005 14 fucking years ago.
That middle weight.
Yup.
14 fucking years ago.
You don't have to stop and think
about what an insane career that is.
And his last two fights,
um,
w I think you last fight
was Craig [inaudible].
Is that who he fought last smashed?
That dude smashed and then
smashed Micky gall dude.
He,
he's the,
uh,
he's the mascot for Jackson's.
Right?
Like if there's a logo,
it's Diego Sanchez.
Yeah.
And every prayer,
but he knows that his Brendan chubs voice.
I sound like Alec Jones Right now.
Not,
not loud enough.
Yeah,
you're right.
Yeah.
You sound like Chubb with a cold.
I don't see,
I don't feel sick.
You don't feel sick,
so it's just a sore throat,
I think.
Yeah.
But how's your throat just go?
We screaming at someone.
No,
I was chilling.
I did two purchasing wolf howls.
Sometimes my voice goes,
I'm not saying,
oh,
that's so great.
That's weird.
Cause I am sick a little bit.
Really?
Yeah.
Well I had it over the weekend and
yesterday I felt like dog shit.
Do you work out?
I worked out,
uh,
not yesterday,
but Saturday.
Worked outside of the,
it probably wasn't a good idea.
They say when you work out,
when you're seeking mates at
worst you can system's down.
I usually show up.
Do it too.
I lifted too,
and you know,
it's not smart.
No,
but I,
I,
I'm okay today I'm just like a little,
little worn out,
but my voice is all right.
You should need some rest.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I'll be fine.
I'm traveling doesn't help.
No,
it's the worst man because always I
always take the first flight back cause I
want to see my family and mostly,
yeah,
I got the,
that makes it worse.
Yeah.
I was up at five.
Um,
so Micky gall in that fight,
he asked for that fight.
That was a fight.
He was begging Dana white to give him.
He thought it was a good fight for him.
He thought it was a good match up.
I don't know why people think that.
I guess cause like he's been knocked out.
Right.
Ally Quinta.
Kao Damn.
Um,
uh,
Matt Brown.
Kao Dem,
but he's a big name has
been doing for a long time.
So these young guys go,
oh,
I grew up watching him.
Let me get him.
Well they,
I think they also think he's been
doing it for so long and they're right.
Yeah.
But he's still so fucking tough,
man.
He has all the skills.
He still has all the skills and his
ground and pound his fucking for Roche's.
And once he's on the ground,
then he doesn't,
I mean,
if there's a hole in Diego's game,
you would have to say
against like elite Strykers.
He has a real problem.
Like guys like Matt Brown,
he's going to have problems.
He's just not as fluid as those guys,
you know?
Yeah.
Diego's grappling to amazing,
amazing,
amazing.
And his ferocity can not eat question.
He's just mental games.
Savage.
Just to think about the enthusiasm Diego
has after all these years in the game,
all these years in the game,
unbelievable craze.
How many years,
how many years?
What we know?
14 years in the UFC.
But he fought before that he was,
he was a veteran.
I mean he had several
fights before the UMC.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Crazy.
How long he's been doing it.
And again,
how long he's been doing it
and how much he loves it still.
And he says CBD is really helping him.
He's got his own CBD,
2002 Damn motherfuckers.
17 years in years.
He fought Michael Johnson.
2000 same Michael Johnson.
No Way.
Like my mind,
Michael was six years.
What's that?
His name would probably
be a tag there if it was.
Yeah.
What?
Right.
That's not Michael.
Wow.
He fought Shannon rich on his third fight.
Shannon rich has like a
million fights kick on.
Shannon rich,
which in my get Gaiman the joker
old school to then click on Shannon.
Rich,
how many fights is it?
Yeah,
I'm gonna say he's got,
how many does it say?
Holy Shit.
Say the regular doses.
53 it's Jesus Christ.
It's the worst record of every sad.
It's crazy.
That is crazy.
Shout out to that guy
though for keeping with it.
You know that is crazy.
Lost 79 times.
Jesus Christ.
42 kickboxing.
Oh my God.
At 42 kickboxing matches.
Jesus Christ.
Blake kickbox and he's kind of killing it.
35 and seven not bad,
but that's an insane amount of experience.
But just stop and think
about 17 years in Diego.
Still slinging and so much enthusiasm.
That's the crazy part.
It's not just that he's fighting that he
fights fires the fucking angry cause he
had his own CBD company
now gave me some of it.
Any good?
I haven't tried it yet.
He just gave me,
he gave me some bottles of his stuff,
but he's,
he mean he really believes in CBD.
A lot of fighters do.
It's helping them lot whereby it,
yeah,
it's amazing.
Amazing.
Stop Spectrum CBD oil.
That's what I,
yeah,
I mean there's so many good companies now,
but uh,
you know another fight.
That was crazy.
How about Colby and Pedro?
Munoz?
Are you talking about,
you're talking about code?
Well,
you skipped past.
This is a beat.
Oh,
Jeremy Stephens,
which I thought crazy.
Crazy and no,
I mean for as a beat to beat
the number six out in the world.
Yeah,
it was good.
What'd you think?
Um,
I didn't think it helps a beet stock
because there's so much hype on him.
You didn't
really,
well,
first of all,
he's fighting Jeremy.
Steve Agree.
Jeremy Stevens is fucking dangerous.
You can't ask any mistakes with that guy.
You didn't think you look good though.
I thought it looked okay.
I didn't think he has stock went
through the roof with that fight.
You didn't walk away
from that fight going,
oh my God,
I can't wait to see him fight again.
Look good.
But when you,
when you hear Mark Henry's
coach talk about them.
I mean they talk about him
like he's the next fucking,
did you see that three 60 roundhouse kick?
He tried.
Yeah.
That missed the shit so fast.
He's really fast and his,
his round kick to the
body is just so fast.
Like lightning.
Amazing.
Throw such a to such a talent.
So technical to everything
he does is very smooth.
Doesn't get hit.
It doesn't play that game.
No,
no.
It doesn't play the game
that Cody Garbrandt played.
The Patriot Cody got flight was crazy.
I just see losses in a row.
Three,
nine,
three k hours in a row.
I just couldn't believe he was
standing with him like that.
He got,
I'm hurt.
And then he got her and then he was
determined to take him out and then they
were literally going,
all right.
Hand Hook right hand or
right hand on someone fell.
Yeah.
And Pedro can take a shot.
So can Cody.
Yeah,
eight shots.
He ate some big ones,
but it makes no sense if you're Cody.
So technical.
I know it doesn't make any sense the head,
but he said he got head
button and just saw a red,
but he definitely did.
He definitely got headbutted.
Aaron Peko and he talked about it.
He said he saw a red
like got angry about it.
Yeah.
He can't do that.
You got to fight Intel.
I mean obviously it's
super easy for us to say,
you know,
sitting here drinking coffee.
Yeah.
Don't fight it.
Don't fight her angry bro.
You know?
It's easy to say,
but that's also what makes him so dynamic.
I agree.
It's what got him to the party,
but as a former fighter,
it's like coming off two losses,
which I've been there.
You're usually a little more like,
I am not going to go down.
That road had been knocked out
twice and know how that ends.
Yeah.
If I get hit,
let's learn from our mistakes.
Right,
right.
That's what's the troubling part.
Yeah.
And he,
he has a speed advantage Patrell monies.
That's very good timing.
But I think Colby has a speed advantage
technique and speed on the feet on the
ground.
It's all Pedro on the feed down all day.
I mean,
Cody Garbrandt still only 27 years old
and still could be world champion again.
No,
no doubt about it.
Well three losses.
Pedro Munoz.
Okay.
Can you played that game loss.
But then the other two are Tj Dillashaw.
Right.
Okay.
Still the champ has your number.
Who gives a fuck?
And in both of those fights
he hurt Tj Dillashaw.
He's just gotta be more cautious
and fight more technical,
more disciplined.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
wouldn't be a bad idea to
get some mental coaching,
you know,
get some game plan coaching,
which he might've been doing.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'm just speculating.
I don't know who he's training
his striking with either.
But you know,
to mix things up more and be more
unpredictable would also be a good thing.
I mean,
obviously the,
the,
the last exchanges were
just not predictable at all.
It's fun for,
I mean,
not unpredictable,
all fully predictable.
Just right hand,
right hand,
just chaos.
You know,
and think about his last one.
He beat Dominic Cruz,
which is,
you've got to be cerebral
in that fight to be done.
The cruise.
Yeah.
He had Dom's number.
I mean,
and it was a different kind of fighting.
It's interesting.
Dom said that he did the exact
thing that Cody did in their fight,
that he got hit and he got
emotional and he fought reckless.
Dom did.
Yeah.
And that Tom went after Cody.
He said,
I know what it's like.
You just,
you lose your game plan and you start,
you get wild.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's hard to see him get Kayo
three times in a row like that.
He's going to be fine.
I hope so.
Who learned from it?
But here's the thing,
when you're ranked,
was he number two in that division?
It's not like,
all right,
let's give you a warm up fight.
Like it's not boxing.
There's no warm ups.
He's going to get Jimmy Rivera or
fucking stir aljamain and mean.
Yeah.
It's like,
and you know those guys might argue that
they don't want him because he's lost
three times in a row.
Jimmy Rivera's come off a loss too.
That's true.
Sterling actually called him out,
which is weird cause he's ranked,
you know he's ranked five I think,
but he's coming off a win,
you know a huge one.
So with sterling sterling
called out Covington.
Yeah,
I mean um,
Brant.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm saying Colby Covington already cause
I'm already thinking that much about
him and that marketing.
Yeah,
well he's good at talking shit and getting
his name out there and it's the best
thing for the welterweight
division right now.
After [inaudible] just
dominated Tyron Woodley,
I was blown away by that fight.
Me Loan a one hour
texting each other.
It's weird cause I had people around the
house to watch the fights and they were
like,
God,
this fight so boring.
And I look online like,
God,
this is brutal.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I was one of the greatest title fight
performances I've ever seen her.
For him to do that to
Woodley and dismantle him,
you don't understand.
You have no idea what you're watching.
It's fucking insane.
It's not just insane
that he dismantled them,
which is for sure insane,
but also his fucking gas tank Uzman was
pushing on the pedal for five fucking
rounds.
Never let off the gas.
How about the way he looked in
between rounds went down to me,
it was his mentality.
When you look from the first round,
she was,
they break it up and then you
ready standing there like this.
I'm like,
oh,
she was,
do you know that word was
that he had a fractured foot?
Correct.
So he took a fucking cortisone
shot coming into that fight.
Imagine that savage.
Imagine that and still no
problems with his endurance.
Apparently didn't train the whole
week of just didn't do shit.
Still made the weight.
No problem.
But think about what he has to do.
His coach is going,
I,
you got to go in there.
You got to out grapple.
How maneuvered Tyron Woodley,
who's one of the best
welterweights of all time?
Well,
he,
how does he get taken down?
How did empties and get taken down?
Who doesn't get taken down?
Literally also was kind of,
I dunno,
he's 37 I don't know if it's,
he just didn't show up what happened,
but he's 36 [inaudible] 36 either way.
Either way.
He's been doing it for a hot second.
This is why I feel bad for wood thing.
Maybe you know Joe,
but Woodley was always that guy
where he didn't get along with Dana.
He was kind of difficult to deal with,
did it his way and made some demands.
One of the big fight and then
it never happened for him.
He just,
he was in a big draw and,
but he could get away with
that when he was champ.
Right now that he's not champ
the road frame to get back,
it's going to be so fucking tough.
Right.
Because of what he did when he was champ.
That's why I feel bad for Woodley and
he's one of the greatest to ever do it.
He is one of the greatest to ever do it.
And I was making the argument
before this fight that he,
you could obviously you could argue that
if he beats Huseman he is the greater
correct.
He's in the,
the,
the greatest is George Saint Pierre,
right?
He was a legend at welterweight.
You,
you look at his career,
I mean how many years was George Chamfer?
Was it six years or something crazy?
They had the most title.
So you have George,
Matt Hughes and Woodley Matthews has
legend status because he was the original,
right?
He was,
I mean he was the first wrestler that
really developed rock solid submission
skills.
The F the fights with frank Trigg.
The,
I mean he,
when he,
um,
armbar George Saint Pierre
and their first fight,
I mean he was amazing.
But then the new school was George,
you know,
George was the best
welterweight of all time.
But I was saying that the,
he's in the running right now.
If you consider the opponents,
he beat Wonderboy twice,
knocks out Robbie Lawler,
the win the title,
and then goes on from there.
Beats Damien Maia.
Um,
I mean you,
you look at how he beat Darren till for
some he was an underdog and then Darren
till fight,
which didn't make any sense to
me cause I thought everybody,
it,
I got excited too.
I thought Dan,
until is gonna win that really?
I did see I thought
Darren tills very good,
but I did not too much.
I never saw him on the ground.
I never saw a real wrestler take
him down and ground and pound.
I didn't know what he had off his bass
there until it can be a prompt for
Huseman.
What really is size?
Yeah,
I think it's going to prom and
Dan has committed to one seven.
He still is.
He still,
I think that especially
now that one 70 cause what?
What is if you are a fan of fighting,
what is fun?
Is Woodley be an out the
welterweight division.
So Fun,
right?
Because now,
Ooh,
spin Colby,
you got Ben at Ben Ascar in there now.
Now Deron till has a
shot to be a champion.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
even though Robbie Lawler lost that fight,
God damn,
he looked good.
He looked good physically,
like at the way,
and he looked Jack Best
I've ever seen him.
He looked amazing.
Apparently he had a tremendous
strength and conditioning routine.
Yeah.
He looked real good and he was
fighting fucking for Roche.
It's like the Robbie Lawler of old,
he didn't look at all diminished and I
think maybe the time off was good for him
because he had to get a ACL surgery.
Yeah.
So it might have been dealing with
something before his last fight.
We don't know.
Do you think maybe it was to where
Ben Adkins very so one dimensional.
He didn't have to worry
about the striking at all.
Um,
there's a little bit of that for sure.
But the fucking fight started because
he launched Ben Astroneer to the ants.
Slammed him on his fucking head,
which was crazy then and tough as shit.
Here's the other thing.
Yes.
Ben One controversially,
we don't know that there was still what,
two minutes left in that fight,
dude,
I've been watching their
dog with that much time.
It could've got pretty
dice for fucking um,
uh,
Robbie Lawler a dicey.
We can't just Chaco Benz.
Uh,
Ben,
I think you put it on his
Twitter or his Instagram page.
We see Robbie Lawler's arm
go limp to Dick goes limp.
Now here's the question.
Did it go limp because he just let it
go cause he was trying to like let you
know,
just let it go cause he's trying to
like that's hang on cause the choke.
He was like he's squeezing really hard,
is going to tire his arms out.
Robbie said it wasn't under his chin now
but here's the thing and this is people
need to stop saying that you
have to be under the chin.
Could choke a guy unconscious.
You can do both.
You can choke a guy on
conscious across his face for,
she can go across the face,
right like this.
If you have a real squeeze,
you have like a Marcello Garcia squeeze.
You could put a guy asleep.
Think I'll strong Ben is to,
Ben has a real squeeze,
phenomenal squeeze.
Strange and he's in this position.
Would that bulldog,
you can get a lot of
leverage in that position.
I mean,
I don't know how he's gripping
as how much torque the torque.
So I don't know if he went out and then
band let them go a little bit and then
he popped right back awake.
That's what he's saying.
You're your natural movement though.
If you go,
if you're fighting a choke,
your your natural Mr. Hold
onto it is not to go lip.
That's,
that's true.
That's why I'm like,
maybe he was out.
We thought he was out.
Yeah,
he thought he was out.
But in all fairness,
I thought Ben was out
earlier me to or not.
They're going to stop there.
We're stopping Robbie slamming.
I'm like,
he's out.
He's out.
He was,
fuck.
I thought he was out,
but damn,
he can take a fucking shot.
He can take a fucking shot.
Robbie hitting one somamers
hosts nervous for that fight.
Ooh,
it's crazy.
We've had him up so much love so much.
And when he came to Daddy's do Goober,
dad bod,
I was like,
damn,
this justice terrible,
but let's figure this out.
Let's see.
Do you have a video of it?
Check both of his pages.
I don't see he posted it.
He posted it today.
I think it was a Twitter.
Yeah,
I think it was Twitter and I think
maybe he might've either re posted it or
replied to it or repost it with a comment.
Oh,
he says this is what happened and
it's in the conscious to comment.
Okay,
well let's see it when he
said this is what happened.
Then go to whatever he was commenting
on the hand and you'll see the video
whenever he was commenting
on is the video the only,
basically they were saying
that in the video that he see.
Let's check it out here.
Jack Sparrow.
There it goes.
See carefully.
You'll see that Ben loosen his
chalk chalk choke a little bit,
and then herb dean touch.
Click on that.
Click on that goes to a long thread.
Yeah,
but if you go to the top of that thread,
you'll see the video.
There it is right there
at the top right there.
Watch this.
So check this out.
Look at the arm.
See that right there.
That's not a normal move up,
but,
but look,
but Robbie does give them the thumbs up.
That's the other thing that you're not
seeing that it's not a normal movement,
but it is a tight squeeze.
It does look like his arm went limp.
I think it went out for a second.
Got In camp and came to,
well,
herb said,
what herb is saying is he told Bam
to stop when the arm went limp,
when the arm went.
Lynn Ben said is that he's lightening
up and then he lightened up and then
Robbie came back to life.
That's fair.
That is entirely possible,
folks.
It's entirely possible.
I do not know.
But I do know that Robby Lawler is a
classy motherfucker because he complained
for a little.
Say what the fuck does all right man,
good job.
Good fight.
He's been in the game
so long and he's like,
he can see him.
He goes out,
he's got to grind.
He's got a great attitude.
He really does.
And uh,
I don't think it stock
dropped in that fight.
I really don't know.
No,
I really don't.
And I would like to see the rematch.
I don't,
well,
I want to see it again.
I mean,
he says no,
but Ben Says No.
Yeah.
Ben Says he didn't want to
fight him in the first place.
Why would you write a fucking murderer?
But he was so amped up for that fight too.
So angry and like you
could see in his face.
He knew what this meant.
Dude.
How about Ben versus Uzman
mother fucking fight shit.
Oh Damn.
Until yeah,
Ben,
your performance,
your shit.
You barely one.
Your ugliest.
Fuck.
Your Chin is too big not to miss.
You have no respect for no one.
Oh,
did I say your curly headed fuck.
See in London,
muppet well till has a tough
fight in London though too.
Yeah.
Mazda dolls.
No joke.
A very technical guy.
He's got a wrestling to men.
He's getting everything very good at
everything and very good wrestling.
And I think that's probably where he's
going to try to put Darren till after
that Woodley fight.
He said that's a tough life.
It's a bad situation for Woodley man.
Because a you're gonna people are gonna
say oh he was doing all that stuff with
TMC.
Oh he's got a rap album coming up.
He's opening for he's,
he's doing rap concerts fair though.
Right?
Yeah.
That's fair.
That's fair criticism cause cause I've
always been on that side of you and you
know more than anyone.
He told me to get the fuck out
cause when you're one foot in.
Yup.
Cause what's instrument doing when
Woodley's in the studio going hard,
going hard was men is all in.
He's all in.
You think who's been wants show.
If I can wait up do's and be like hey
dude I'll pay for a show free on Tmz to go
get the fuck out my face.
Fuck out of my face.
That's what he's going to say.
Get the fuck you probably get angry at.
You get the fuck out of my face.
That TMZ shit dude.
I was,
I was telling everybody for years,
people have been scared
of Huseman for years.
But now you see why now you see,
before you were seeing
people were scared of him,
but he wasn't beating anybody.
That was world class.
He wasn't,
he wasn't getting those top 10 guys.
Amy,
Maya,
right?
Yeah.
We got dos saint to Damien Maia fight
will forever be marred by the fact they
separated them when Damien had one
hook and he was trying to take us back,
dude was that fucking homeboy,
the guy who kept saying on
come up with that daughter,
oh my God,
I don't know what he's doing.
Or you didn't see who that was?
Go go to a Damien Maia versus um,
Kamara Huseman and see who,
who separated them.
Cause the Ref Matt,
uh,
Matt,
the Terra Sarah was going
fucking crazy about that.
And he's 100% right.
Do you know how difficult it
is to get ahold of a guy like,
Ooh,
spawn like that?
And to have one hook in standing up and
to be working to take his back and for
them to separate him,
it is nonsense.
Pure nonsense.
How much harder it is.
That's hard.
Yeah.
How much heart is to take
Woodley down in control?
Yes.
And as you stand them up.
Yup.
If I'm Moose,
man,
what the fuck are you doing?
Do.
Yeah,
but it mean you stop and think
that you should come down.
You stop and think about Damien Maia,
his last fight.
Right?
Who the fuck?
Who the fuck did he just
choked unconscious fuck out of?
Who was that?
Who Was it?
Who did you just choke out?
Someone really good.
A young kid that they fed.
Okay.
So here it is.
That's not Goddard.
Who is it?
Uh,
is the bald feller.
Which bald feller?
So here's,
um,
so here's a,
it's hard to tell who that referee is.
I can't see the face.
So it loose man in them.
They're,
they're exchanging ooze.
My cracked him.
Who is it?
Is it Chris Taione?
I know two referees.
I know three.
No.
Um,
it's Leon.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well for whatever reason,
what was God thinking though?
I don't know what he was.
Thank you.
And then he's shade online at Jon Anik.
What did he say?
Seeing your commentary was off.
So was annex.
You got my commentary on?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know what I did to say.
I didn't say anything
bad about Mark Goddard.
I said I don't,
I disagree with them standing up.
I don't know why he said
the commentary was off,
but Dominick Cruz did say
that he can't wrestle.
And the reason why he's standing
him up his cause he can't wrestle.
Mark honored.
Yes.
No,
he said that he's,
he was saying that about Mark Goddard.
Correct.
We've seen the referee can't wrestle.
He threw shade.
It got her.
I,
I'm nothing but respect for God.
Although I don't agree with
his decision in that fight.
I do not agree with standups.
I don't like stand up higher.
Your Garden.
I do too.
He's a great referee in that moment.
He's wrong.
Well,
he's probably very emotional.
Listen,
your job is not to intervene with the
trajectory of the fight when your job is
to protect the fighters.
No one fuck up.
Ooh.
Spins.
Biggest fight of his life by standing up.
Because what happens this,
and we've seen it.
Labs if be stood them up and he goes,
you know what,
fine.
I feel good.
Knocks him out.
Right.
You got it.
It can happen.
It can't happen.
What did he say about me?
He didn't specifically call you off.
What'd he say?
Where did the only thing wildly
inconsistent is your and your cocoms
commentators like election
observation of actual events.
I will book Joe Rogan's ass.
That's wrong.
That's so rude.
I didn't see that.
I just made that up.
The only thing wildly inconsistent is
your and your cocoms recollection and
observation of actual events.
I'll save my side for later.
Well,
that doesn't make any sense.
Recollection of actual events.
I don't know what he's trying
to say there and cocoms.
I didn't say anything bad
about him other than that.
I don't agree with the standups job.
Dominick Cruz said that he can't wrestle
and I don't know if mark got Russell.
I know he knows how to referee
this compared to Dominick Cruz.
He cannot wrestle,
so dom,
it's fine to say that,
but also John Annika
and harden the paints.
Awesome.
Yeah,
I like that you are way off.
What's wildly,
wildly inconsistent is correct.
Cause Herb Dean is the gold
standard in my opinion.
And Herb Dean,
even though he,
that thing with Robbie
Lawler is controversial,
kind of look at it and I go,
the arm went limp.
I can see how he made that.
I said,
see that?
I could see,
I think it's unfortunate and
it may have been a mistake,
but it might not have been a mistake.
I,
I'm,
I'm still,
I'm still glad I'm not at all not,
hey look man,
his job his fucking way harder
than mine a hundred times harder.
Heard Herb Dean's job is to protect
the fighters and to stop fights to make
calls.
I don't want to be that guy that I
thought that guy gets fucking hated on it.
Never loved herb.
Never gets low and like something,
don't know whenever it gets love,
but with mark daughter
don't be the guy tried to,
John replied,
he said,
I always try to be respectful.
We just call it like we see it too.
But there's an arrogance with
which you deal with the fighters,
commentators and many in this sport.
And I find it off putting,
Whoa,
one man's take.
And I'm quite sure you'll give yours
to for everyone to hear why I'm manic.
World Stone Am Dad.
I'm okay.
So I believe John Eck was offered to
the inconsistent between each referees
decisions of when to
separate the fighters.
And John said exactly.
That's what I was referring to,
that [inaudible] that
two of the consensus,
Beth best referees of the
game would handle those two
situations so differently.
I understand the athletes are different,
but there are parallels to be drawn.
John is 100% correct.
Hundred percent a hundred percent correct.
And I'm at us,
Bro.
I'm,
I feel bad that Mark Goddard respond
the way he did because it's not very
professional and I think it's very
emotional and I think he's probably just
feeling the heat.
Yeah.
Hard on them.
You feel that heat,
you get angry,
you know.
But,
uh,
I like Mark Goddard,
a lack of Milan and I think he's a very
good refereeing top one or two reps in
the business.
I love mark daughter.
He fucked that up.
My question is I wonder who is telling
them they should stand things up when
they shouldn't stand things up.
I wonder if pressure heath,
the pressure he feels from the audience.
You think the crowd,
maybe it could be that
British people are very nice.
You know,
sometimes in English people there
when you got to worldclass wrestlers
and this guy's impossible take down.
He's won the best of all time.
Yup.
Let it go.
Well I think let it go.
Period.
I just,
I do not agree with standups cause I think
of a guy can hold you down like this.
What I was saying about Ben Askern,
if guy look,
Ben asking can hold you down and give
you nuggies until the fights over.
Yeah.
Do something about it.
Exactly.
You not cheating.
No.
If he's not cheating,
keep it up.
Do you know how hard it is to control
Woodley on the down and the only outside
of fucking minutes?
You have five minutes to sneak a choke in.
Five minutes to hold on to
him and beat him up and uh,
look,
awkward it to this man.
He didn't even fucking care.
He got stood back up,
didn't complain.
We're right back at him and
took him down again and again.
He's a monster.
Went cool story,
Bro.
He is fucking hard to deal with for Colby,
for everyone on the planet earth.
But stylistically,
when you look at the fight for Colby,
Alec Ula,
Colby does well.
He does that.
The thing about [inaudible]
is he's got power.
He's got striking,
he's got wrestling.
But even maybe more
importantly RDO for days here,
oh is mine is a fucking bank fault.
It's Fort Knox not getting in the press.
How adorable was it?
Him and his little daughter.
Oh Dude,
I almost cried.
Just such a big chew.
I'm such a bitch pussy that have kids.
Me Too.
I'm like,
oh,
I know.
So cute.
And just how happy mom
and wife for real extra.
They're like P diddy
extra.
Hey Manny,
he's so bad in the world.
Imagine what it feels like to have your
husband when the fucking world heavy
world welterweight title to
beat Tyron Woodley knife block.
My wife take a hot bath,
the fuck out of here and my mom sure
as fuck wouldn't be in the case.
Hey man,
I feel like when someone wins like that
they could do whatever they want me.
Carter's mom's always in the cage is dads.
She not fucking true.
Throwing out promo codes.
Listen man.
Oops.
Mine.
I feel like he's only like,
what is he 31 or 32 how old is he smiling?
Ready to fucking sad.
He can be the champ for a long time.
Scared me.
He's not doing it in person.
Of course you have assessed,
but when he's not cutting
on my palm beach show,
I let,
what the fuck are you doing?
How much do you weigh?
I don't know.
We were the same size.
He's fucking huge.
Well,
it gets you scared me.
Size of he scared me.
Well he's,
but he's big like a super athlete
and not like a bodybuilder,
which is on my face.
Goosmann what's the word like when
you look at the way Tyron is big?
Tyrons more thick.
Like his legs are fisherman.
He Tarryn's fat.
Look at it at the height difference.
We get his fucking back.
Look at those so tall.
Look out.
Talia is men and wide.
He looks scary where all these
paints were ogling at them.
I'm on is not so much.
These are monster that the face paint
thing was a last minute decision to Susie
had to do is face Susan the makeup lady.
Should I do his face last year?
She has when she's the best.
She's such a nice lady and she pitched,
they had to make sure that
they had the right color paint,
you know,
to do the Nigerian flag on his face.
Dude,
he might be champ for a long time.
There's a great match ups.
Oh my God.
Welterweight is so fucking fun
and don't sleep on Mazda da folks.
You know Jorge Mas de Darle stills capable
of beating something in money fucked
up cowboy Ho Masala Dal is the real deal.
The real deal.
The Darren tail man,
he's my dark horse.
You still think so unless he
goes 85 but he's a motherfucker.
You know what happened in
that till fight with Woodley.
He didn't land a single
significant strike in two rounds.
He didn't rent anything in the first
round and he didn't land anything in the
second round.
Just understand that this is the big show.
This is the world title shot.
You come out to fucking Neil diamond,
sweet Caroline.
The whole deal.
Everybody's singing along to wonder.
That's London,
but,
but he lands nothing.
All right,
well here's this Woodley threw
one punch and five rounds.
No,
that's not true.
It happened.
Literally hit him.
He was very tentative.
He,
well he was doing the smart thing.
The smart thing is you wait
and you counter because
Woodley's so God damn fast,
that smart thing paid off when he landed.
That big right hand dropped him.
And then the other problem with Darren
till is that on the ground on his back,
he didn't have anything,
didn't have anything off.
We didn't have anything to use.
Raw shorts for sure.
But if you can move,
you've got to be or should do something
to protect yourself and something to
tie.
He also didn't see the choke coming.
That also could be because he was rocked.
Look,
if you look at the way
he dispatched cowboy,
insanely impressive.
If you look at the way he beat Wonderboy,
also impressive in wonder boys,
a world class striker don't friend.
He feed them and dry them.
Wonderful.
You spend one boys a hard code to crack.
He's a hard code to crack.
Yes.
And especially if Wonderboy have some
time off to recover and sometime gone,
gone through those two
big five round three,
five round fights.
The fight did till fight was
a five round fight as well.
So those are hard,
man.
They're hard on your body.
Hard going through training camp.
And I want to say that I think Wonderboy
had a knee injury to that he's might've
gotten surgery on and he's hasn't maybe,
but yeah,
that might might've made up the ne the
point is one of the welterweight division
is fun as fuck.
Fucking every division's fun as fuck.
Bantam.
I just opened up with Pedro
Munoz heavyweights Kinda
crunk now to Johnny fucking
Walker.
Yeah.
Dude.
Johnny Tor.
Okay.
Steven Juan Thompson said is moving,
was out the window after Derek Kill,
uh,
kicked a knee kick out.
Okay.
He's also saying that he doesn't think
that those kicks should be allowed,
which is crazy for someone to say that
kicks people on the head spinning wheel
kits.
Okay.
It says,
uh,
it was almost like the dude
was trying to put me out.
Thompson told Ariel Helwani.
Yeah,
yeah.
But he was definitely
trying to damn cage fight.
He hit me in the knee
and after that my movie,
it was pretty much out the window
is more focused on keeping my knee.
It was just another thing
to think about out there.
Well that's a strange attitude,
you know what I mean?
Maybe that comes because he came from
a karate background and not a Moitai
background.
All the tops on the show.
Thompson said he was unsure
of targeting the knee.
Would that kick like that is legal?
Well,
I will tell you it's legal.
It's definitely illegal.
So it,
so our heel hooks,
which are way worse,
I mean do a spinning up.
He says,
hopefully it's nothing major,
but it sucks,
man.
It really does.
Disappointed by the whole situation than
coming out of it with an injury like
that.
It only makes it all worse.
He has a fight coming up.
Yeah.
Pedis.
Oh that's right.
So he must've healed it up
or got surgery or whatever.
I just,
I don't understand that.
I don't understand that kind of thinking.
I mean I don't,
he said I was trying to hit
the guy hard or really was,
I was just saying unable to put
myself in a situation to do so.
And the reason for that is because he
kicked your knee and she is a technique.
Yeah.
It's a technique I'm using.
It's a fucking legit technique.
It's going to occur.
You said against Romero.
Look I don't,
yes,
and Romero use it against
when we first got it,
yeah,
we're doing that and he
went right after the storm.
You fucked my knee up and the
first friend I'm like fuck it.
And the second fight,
listen,
it is,
it is just as valid and maybe safer
than kicking someone in the head.
It's easier to do for sure than
kicking someone in the head.
But,
so what if you can kick someone in
the fucking head with a wheel kick?
That is the worst thing you could do
to a person when a boy has no point.
He's just point.
It was just sad about the fight.
Yeah,
it just,
it's unfortunate.
But again,
I think a lot of that is because he came
from that karate background and he came
from a above the waist style
karate background initially.
You know when Duke Rufus was
cornering his brother Rick Rufus,
when Rick roof has fought a,
I forget the gentleman's
name from Thailand.
Um,
I think Lauren's Kenshin has it as
the most important kickboxing match in
history.
God Damn,
I forget who that because we realized
how critical cause this was in Rick.
Rufus was his prime.
He was the man.
I mean Rick roof,
the jet,
he would do wild shit.
Man.
Jumped three 60 tourney
side kicks to the face.
He would hit guys and knock them out
with a hook kicks and front leg Brown.
Here he goes,
Chang,
try this name.
Chang Pooh cat cat song.
Grit.
I fucked that up.
I'm sure he would've said at Duke
would have said the name perfect.
But at the point is at
the end of the fight,
after the Thai gentleman destroyed Rufus,
his legs and stopped him.
Duke who's a world champion himself said
that he didn't think that it took any
skill to do that because that's how
a lot of those tie guys thought.
He watched the end of this man,
watch the end of this.
You can't walk.
He could barely walk.
But Watch,
they say go ahead and this
dude comes out and goes,
he knows what to do.
They just get back to tax these legs and
this dude's a beast to the thighs and
this dude whack.
He just fucking those legs up.
Hands up high and just whack.
Look at this dude.
Who's the Ralph?
Well,
they didn't know any better up there.
That's how they did it back
there with a karate kick.
The Ref.
We're a fucking karate gie.
The reps got a black belt.
Yeah,
he does look at that
whack plank in the ass.
Yeah,
those,
those leg kicks and that was it.
So after it was over at Duke who I
think was only like 19 at the time,
said he didn't think that took any skill.
Obviously Duke doesn't think that now
he evolved and became a world champion
himself.
It's just ignorance,
but that sort of stuff.
There he is right there
like a young baby face,
Duke roof.
We'll play it so he could hear him say it
the way the cookie crumbled
back it up a little so
I can hear him say that.
I'm not sure.
I just know that he's in pain and the
leg kicks with only thing that stopped
him.
Like I did not touch me
anywhere else in the body.
You know?
I think you know that Rick
should've won the fight.
He had the guy out there
are three major fowl,
but the way the cookie crumbles tonight,
he said later that he didn't think
that it took skill to do that,
but which is they just
didn't know any better.
I was like,
this is how I
kicked so hard to,
that style is so good.
The Thai style is so God damn good.
It's so good.
There are hidden movements.
Yeah.
Well the Thai style with the
other techniques is the best.
If you got that Thai style,
but you know how to throw sidekicks,
you know,
throw everything else.
Wonderboy.
Yeah.
Jon Jones,
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones was stolen.
No fucking throwing everything.
It's a very interesting watching him,
man.
He's doing a lot sidekicks now and
spinning back kicks turning side to slant
into the body.
Yeah.
He's throwing a lot of sidekicks.
He sees her,
he throws a lot of everything man.
But he fucks you up.
He's just,
and he's so good at keeping
guys in the back foot.
Just dismiss.
Just taken away there.
Arsenal.
I want to say this though because this
is something that's coming up and it's
actually kind of pissing me off.
What's that?
There's somebody who just,
a bunch of people that have been saying
should Anthony have take have like laid
down after you took that
illegal knee and won the title.
Who set this?
Ariel Helwani a bunch
of other people said it.
I think Ariel was suggesting or asking
whether or not he should have some Beta
male shit.
Well,
it's crazy because the guy should
be praised for he ate the knee.
He was okay.
And then he wasn't even
thinking about quitting.
Yeah.
I didn't even go through my mind.
Is that once your my mind
that someone might do that?
Some people say Smith.
No,
it wasn't was even a thought.
nope.
Nope.
It wasn't a thought I don't
agree with and I wasn't like,
oh,
we should all give him praise for this.
I was like,
no,
why would he do that?
Well that's,
that's who he is.
But some people like,
let's be honest,
and I think Chelsea would probably admit
to this if he took that illegal knee,
he might say that's it.
Can't go on.
Sorry.
Rematch.
Well you get the wind chills besman yeah,
I mean you get the,
when you get the title you get a rematch.
I could be wrong.
Child might disagree.
Might say no,
I'm a competitor when I'm in there.
I wouldn't,
wouldn't think that way.
Not,
it is not now his agent,
but the bottom line is like
some people were actually,
she actually suggesting that that that
would be a good option that he was,
the many people have suggested
I saw several peon and
that the fans went hard on
these people that suggested it.
Like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
You're out of your fucking mind class.
That'd be such a bitch move.
Unless he actually couldn't go on.
Yeah.
But we all saw he could.
He goes,
I'm fine.
no,
Yeah,
exactly.
What the Smith Anthony
Smith stock went higher.
Now we go,
Oh shit.
No,
he's top five for sure.
And he looked very good
in the first round,
the first round and looked very good.
John,
his take down defense.
Yes.
Very good.
John started figuring them out.
And John John is so good at forcing
you to fight his fight and for and,
and,
and being first.
He's so good at being first.
First with the kicks first
the punches first forward.
You know,
he doesn't give you a chance.
And that's the thing with Anthony Smith.
Anthony Smith chance was to always be
first if cash Shanthi Smith's fights
prior.
He was a bull dozer comes at you.
John went,
that's what you do.
Cool.
I'm put you on your back foot.
You go first.
Not In mine.
None of my night.
I'm going to go first.
Anthony Smith was defensive
the entire time I can fight.
He just took away all his tools.
He also fought very
technically in the first,
first round.
It was,
he didn't just showing Adam Anthony.
Oh yeah.
For very technical.
John actually the first
Sean got a little wild.
I felt like he almost felt
the pressure of being up,
you know,
minus 800 favorite,
really expensive.
Never seen John thrilled those
wild punches in that first room.
He was trying to get them out of there.
They went,
you know what?
This isn't gonna be as easy.
I thought recalculated
and then dismantle them.
Yeah.
I mean he's the best of all time by far,
by far the best.
But who who,
who in that division
can fuck with him now?
I mean,
um,
exactly.
Santos,
which is,
look,
Santos is a wildcard that mother
fucker can knock out anybody.
I would have liked to see Johnny
Walker not blow his shoulder out.
Celebrate.
And he's fine though.
What?
Listen man,
he could move his arm.
He came in the back and they didn't even,
they're waiting to I think today,
but in the back after he went.
I'm actually good now.
Okay,
so what that must mean.
That must mean that he dislocated it
and then they popped it back in place.
So it could be fine or there could be
some significant tearing inside that
allowed it to dislocate and that
could be a problem in the future.
Okay.
It's fine though.
Let's hope it's still not fine.
John Jones,
yet he hasn't wasted.
Fill that dude up.
It's stem cells is get a bunch of needles
in there and fucking corazon do all
the fucking no,
no more bro.
Don't know.
Give Him cortisones to
give them some stem cells.
The interesting fight for John.
Yes,
he's interesting because Santos throws
fucking nuclear muscles at your head and
you know he did stop Jimmy and Mattawa.
He's,
he stopped several guys
that light heavyweight.
He looks spectacular,
light every way and he stopped
Anthony Smith and their last fight at
middleweight.
I would imagine Santos is almost a
bigger underdog then Anthony Smith.
Um,
I would imagine that too,
but I would imagine that he's not
going to fight like Anthony Smith.
Is he okay?
Was it say I'm fine.
My shoulder's not too bad.
Not too bad is not a good thing to say.
I just need to do some exams and check
to be 100% sure that it was nothing
serious.
Okay.
That doesn't mean it's okay.
Because the thing about shoulder tariffs,
and this is coming from someone
who's had some shoulder issues,
they,
it feels all right until you do something
weird and then it hurts and then
you're like,
fuck.
And then you get an Mri and then
they look at it and they go,
you got some tears in there.
So sometimes he thought,
shit,
I've had pro.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm fucked.
I can't move my shoulder.
Then two days later like,
Whoa,
right,
let's do,
that's usually like sore
tendons or sore muscles.
Which doing the worm.
Yeah,
but he fell face first and
landed on his shoulder.
Weird.
I'm sure he's done doing that.
Maybe man,
I don't know.
It's hard as post fight speech.
Got His Mickey mouse.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
He's a real character.
He's a character when
you work on his English.
But he's didn't go far.
Motherfucker has some POW or flying me.
I was grilling for everyone and I'm,
I've lost track of time when we did
the TV from my backyard and I saw them,
I saw him go,
let's get it on.
I just fucking dropped
everything and sprinted.
Cut Out.
Motherfucker knocks do das seconds.
Yeah.
Well this is his third
fight in the octagon,
but he's fighting Nisha sir.
Chernoff who's a a real,
he said that he's half man.
He's a tank and he's got some serious
grappling skill is chokes the shit out of
everybody.
Choked out Pat Cummings in his last fight
and he chokes the fuck out of people.
But you know,
Johnny Walker,
let's watch it real quick.
I mean fucking the,
but the thing about walkers is so loose.
He came into that fight dancing Paolo,
boom,
look at it.
Here's the thing.
What's he like when someone takes
you down and when the third,
we've got to find out he's a
brown belt in Jujitsu though.
Yeah.
Watch this.
See,
he slapped his own arm on the ground.
Like,
let me see that again.
Just jump on this.
His left arm.
It's his left arm that hurt.
So watch this.
He goes down.
Yeah.
Esther
[inaudible] has a great photo of a,
God damn,
he's lying there.
He was like,
ah,
fuck.
I hurt my arm.
He's going to be fine.
Look,
he might not be fine,
dude.
Dude,
let's wish with the best.
I'm wishing for the best.
Listen,
I'm a fan of the guy.
I'm wishing for the best Santos,
but this,
there are so many videos of football
players celebrating touchdowns and blowing
their ACL out.
Yeah.
It's,
he's like,
hey,
get a doctor.
So he got up and you know
what's interesting is I
was talking to one of his,
uh,
his teammates and they were like,
you know,
you see how Lucy is,
he's like,
he's loose for everything.
That's just how he is with life
dancing.
He was stripping?
No,
he was a dancer I think in Brazil.
Under Brazil style.
Dude.
He's,
and he's a good ship or do this
boy probably made some mud.
Well,
he's a,
he's a real interesting addition
to that division and division.
Finally got some life back.
Santo's him.
Who's the other dude?
Um,
God stud,
which Ah,
it's ranked like number 10.
I think
the way light heavyweights killing it.
Yeah,
I know who you're talking about.
I can't do it either.
Ethnic in,
yeah.
Fuck.
Let me see.
The division.
He's top 15,
top 10.
Let me see.
Let me tell a little bigger
at do is Dominic graves?
Yeah.
Dominic Reyes is a monster.
He's,
he's super athletic too.
The thing about Dominick
Reyes is super smart,
super athletic,
and he's nine and,
oh,
undefeated him in verse,
uh,
Johnny Walker be hell of like,
Ooh.
Yeah.
So many good match.
I'll light heavyweight with the young
guys raises a really good athlete.
The thing about him at separates
him from everybody else.
It's like he has a background.
What do you have a background in football?
Was that what he was,
was so popular?
What was his,
uh,
I'd say Johnny Walkers probably
more athletic than these guys.
He's so big and the way he
moves so big and it weird.
He's from Brazil.
His name's Johnny Walker
is named after whiskey.
Go find a weird,
yeah.
Who knows those Johnny Walker whiskey.
Not just do a deal now I now write
jump on board before this Cha gentlemen
becomes a champ.
Yeah.
Have him wear a Johnnie
Walker tee shirt and ship.
Now again,
light heavyweight will be so much better.
The same thing that
happened in welterweight.
If Jon Jones goes,
how fun boys and goes the heavyweight,
right,
which no one's been on.
These guys are beating John very well.
Could happen.
Nothing's guys are beating.
Well,
John Might Fight Tiago next
and if he fights Tiago,
I mean look,
John Wants to fight five times a year.
So here we are in March.
It's a,
you know,
March 2nd he,
he wins John Easily could
fight in May or June.
We'll fight in June.
I bet.
Easily April,
May,
June,
three months from now.
Yeah.
Easily.
Okay.
I do technical support for,
okay.
He works at an it
technical support and NFL.
See,
hold on.
Paul Dreamt of playing in the NFL,
but didn't he play for high school?
He played in high school and college
and not being drafted here for the sea
wolves.
I don't know.
Okay.
So yeah,
so he played football.
Oh,
at Stony Brook.
Okay,
so he played football and then decided to,
yeah.
Well
still excellent athlete all because
the points didn't get drafted.
But for football,
smarter Shantay standards,
he's super happy and smart as shit.
Yeah.
You know,
that's the thing.
We've talked about this before.
The difference between
the level of athletes,
between the guys that are
going into the NFL and the MBA,
that they're there,
that the height of the height,
dude,
why watch the NFL combine?
There's a guy who was six,
three,
230 pounds,
ran a four three and the
40 or the 40 introvert.
He's a wide receiver.
That isn't the best footwork you've ever
seen has footwork like Dominick Cruz.
It's,
it's mind blowing.
There's a defensive lineman ran
a four four 40 a big fat dude.
That's insane.
That's so fast.
Who 300 pounders ran plus sub five second,
300 pounds.
Sub Five second for her.
That's insane.
That's insane to,
that's so fast.
Have you,
I don't know why I bring
this one in paypal.
I again,
have you ever seen the guy because
we're on the 40th day comes out.
It's the best moment in sports.
He's got so much dick.
It can't be held in any false.
No,
and he bobs up and goes,
oh.
She goes,
what happened?
My Dick fell out,
man,
and they pause and he's this fat black.
Let's see him go,
ready,
go Duh,
Duh,
Duh Duh.
Oh my God.
He fell on his dick.
That's his car.
He tucks it in.
No replay.
They slow it down.
You see this big data fell out,
man.
That is so fun.
Look at the size of that guy.
When they redo it,
let me see.
It helps to like dammit,
you decided to fall down
to cover his own dick.
It's crazy that he's so
confident that his dick is tough.
Look at that.
He went,
let's see.
Break it down.
Oh Jesus.
There it is.
Pops out.
It's like God damn it,
Dick fell out again.
Imagine that kind of a problem.
Imagine she's writing is why.
It's great.
Amazing how many women you
started blowing up his dms like,
I mean when your Dick Falls
out while you're running,
you can't even contain
biggest moment of his height.
He's been waiting to dreaming
of going down the hill.
It's like into the game
and other Ronnie Spa.
I'm sure it's give them a
sturdy pair of compression shorts.
Every dude does.
I get up man.
Let's go again.
This is something I'm not understanding
about dudes who are not wearing
compression shorts with
a cup like a diamond.
Emma makeup in the NFL.
No,
an MMA like guys who get nut shouted
like that when guys Dev reg a regular cup
on like how,
how do you have a regular cup on in,
in 2019 how do you have that when you can
have one of those compression cups and
you're not going to get hurt.
Sometimes those cups are
uncomfortable and it's,
yeah,
they are.
Fuck yeah,
You know what's more uncomfortable?
Can kink kicked in the nuts?
I don't get it.
Kenny Florian,
he used to wear the tie steel cup.
And here's the thing,
I don't think the ties
steel cup should be legal,
but is it is legal or,
oh yeah,
it's a nasty fulcrum.
But not only that,
but even if you're,
um,
you accidentally hit it,
you're hitting a piece of metal.
Like why is it okay to
have a piece of metal?
You could break your foot and a guy can
do something to you and slam that metal
into your face.
I mean,
some weird shit can happen
and you can break a bone.
I mean,
there's,
there's many opportunities
where guys like,
how about this?
A guy shoots in and the
guy hits him with his hips.
Right?
You could hit him with your hips and
catch that Steel Cup right in your fucking
mouth and break your face.
Remember metrio knocked out
Derrick Lewis with his hips.
Remember that?
I thought he hit him in the
right hook or something.
He felt like he just sprawled
and knocked them out.
Really?
Wow.
I don't remember that.
I don't know why did I remember Iste?
And like 13 seconds he hit him with that,
but then he hit him with some punches too.
Right at the end,
but still the hips.
What fucked up.
Just those interesting.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I W I really think that those cups,
like a diamond MMA style
cup should be standard.
And I think diamond MMA
probably has the best one.
I didn't like him when I was fighting
just because they're so uncomfortable.
I'd rather you hit me in the day.
I don't think the diamond
ones are that uncomfortable.
Um,
I forgot.
I bet it's not.
We have one here.
We'll give it to you.
You want to try it out,
but you don't give a fuck anymore.
I don't know what I'd use it for you.
And they're fucking looked on stage good.
Like Gene Simmons and kiss.
He's got one with teeth
on it or something.
Those steel cups though.
Some he used to wear those in Jujitsu.
It was horrible cause
they'd get on top of you.
They look if somebody,
what else did you and the grape vine,
your legs and Doug,
that fucking thing.
And your chest dude.
How about fucking Huseman
fucking grape vining Woodley.
Yup.
Mounted them.
And then,
and then,
um,
I had my boy Todd
Feldman over at my house.
He goes,
could there be anything worse or he goes,
that looks like a bad position to be in.
And I turned around,
I went,
excuse me sir.
The worst,
there's nothing worse than professional
sports than in the UFC when he get
mounted on national TV in front of
millions of people and you just,
it's the most kind of Beta
male move of all time.
You're on your back.
You can't get up.
This means on top of you chest.
It's so embarrassing.
And he tells him the worse.
He held him there for a long time.
All your buddies are watching on damn.
Oh.
And you know the interesting,
it didn't seem like tire and
had the energy to get him off.
Like he didn't even hip escape correctly.
He knows how to hit the
Cape Town's Jujitsu.
Something was up with Woodley.
Yes.
So he looked off,
well I don't know if that it was it or
he's just wilting under the pressure that
Osborne was putting on them.
Here's why.
And I'm not taking anything
away from Moosomin.
I think one of the greatest title fight
performances of all time of all time.
Maybe the best.
That's fine.
I'm fine.
Every minute of every round against
tenets and against a guy who many people
thought w was in the running to be the
thought of as the greatest welterweight
of all time.
Top two.
And if you won that fight,
especially stopped him.
I think you could put
them in that category.
I agree.
So we both agree how impressive it is.
Yeah.
Well I thought he might be off
is right in the opening minute.
Remember Huseman shoots
will grabbed a guillotine,
falls on the wrong side against the cage.
Well world champions don't do that.
He's not there mentally.
Also,
he kept holding onto that chemo.
I was like,
my God,
he's going to get von flute.
And I think the only thing,
I think we're calling it the OSP now Lsp,
the Lsp,
sorry von flue.
But OSP has more von
flue chokes in anybody.
You kind of have to call
it the Osp of in St period.
But then,
but when I saw that fluid
kind of invented it.
Right.
Did he invent that choke?
I doubt he invented it.
I want to know if he invented it because
if he invented he got to give it to
them.
True.
Let's call it the OSPI though.
Way Cooler.
So you went for those peach choke.
Yes.
So he goes for that choke,
but at Woodley's level to do
that and opening rounds in it.
Well he's not ready yet.
He,
he's mentally not firing
right now cause that's,
that's really been a
black belt in Jujitsu.
Yeah.
It was the greatest fighters of all time.
Like you ever seen George
Saint Pierre makeup mental,
not like that.
Never.
Not in a world title.
So I saw that one.
Oh Woodley's off.
You might be right about him having one
foot out the door because being through,
do we figure out if he's 36
or 37 it's 37 in a month.
So basically 37 basically 37
doing all that stuff for TMZ.
I want to say he opened
for Wiz Khalifa recently.
If they have an album together.
Oh Shit Wiz it gonna come on the show.
We're working it out right now.
If you're in need to get so high,
this can be awesome.
That'll be fun.
I want to come in.
Sure.
And how was I sound that
was on fucking Pluto.
Let's fight companions.
Pass these,
these fucking backwoods ones,
man to Caesar a problem.
I was so high.
I was Jones had one,
but it was only tobacco folks.
Um,
yeah,
but,
but both with Woodley,
when we say one foot in,
one foot out,
it's easy to say because in hindsight,
cause eventually he was going to lose.
Yeah.
But before this he was
doing all that stuff,
right.
He beat tail.
He was doing this stuff and
they beat Wonderboy twice.
He was doing this stuff.
So I don't know,
it's just a bad matchup.
But we were looking at these
points he had off night.
Yeah,
he does too much stuff outside dot.
Gun or loose ones.
Just a bad mother.
Fuck.
I think it's all the above.
But lose man is absolutely
a bad motherfucker.
And who knows?
He might have been able to do that
anyway even if Tyron was in perfect
condition.
But here's the question.
Tyrin over the last few fights over the
last few years has been able to control
the pace of the fight.
A 100% he controlled the
pace of the Maya fight.
He the pace,
obviously
Darren till fight was a good,
easy victory for him.
Relatively controlled.
The pace of the Wonderboy fight,
fought smart and then hit him when he
wanted to with big shots and he was the
one who had Wonderboy boy hurt.
Right?
But boy it was never pressing him,
like making it,
forcing his cardio.
But if you go back and watch them,
some of the fights where he had
problems earlier in his career,
like Nate Marquardt,
like Rory Macdonald,
it's someone pushing him,
someone pushing him and this,
you know,
this might,
he might have figured out a way to
look when you're that muscular and he's
fucking ridiculously muscular.
I mean Tyron has legs the
size of a running backs,
his giant athletic and
muscular as fuck too.
He is,
but who spins longer,
longer,
it's different like it's not,
it's not that stacked as Jack Dense,
almost power lifting muscle.
And that muscle is one of the reasons why
Tyron is so fucking fast and powerful,
but it also,
you could make the argument that that
muscle just comes with an unavoidable
price and that what he's been really
able to do is jack his conditioning up as
high as possible and then also do a
really good job of controlling the pace of
fight.
He couldn't do that with Huseman.
Good point.
Could be,
so we don't know.
I feel bad for the guy.
I'm a fan.
I want to see if he wasn't
a hundred percent focused.
I want to see him one more
time focused with Guzman,
but like with,
with um,
um,
with pseudo and TJ caught
behind the air stopped early.
All right.
Rematch for sure.
Rematch.
Other guys where it's quick.
Cain Velasquez,
jds quick rematch.
Let's do it rather back when you get out
class for 25 minutes and there's two,
eight,
10 rounds,
it's tough to,
there's no way off.
See documentary match.
Yes.
So who told you TJ?
You could,
you could really call for
a rematch in that fight.
The UFC is going to make Woodley's path
to that title shot a fucking nightmare
man.
Who stopped that fight?
So Hutto and Tj who stopped that fight?
Who's the referee in that fight?
And I don't know.
Is that herb?
Yeah.
No,
no.
Who Was it?
So Leon Roberts was the one who separated.
Damien Maia.
Robin Roberts.
Was it Leon Roberts?
No.
Oh gentlemen.
Uh,
I forget his name.
Powerful haircut though.
Mm.
So you,
you run that back though
because you suck early.
[inaudible] a tough sell.
They're the biggest names in that debate.
I mean,
if they,
especially if they decide
to do it at flyweight,
they're the only names in that division
except Joseph Benevidez Benevidez who
also won,
he beat so Hutto and a split decision.
He,
there's a real good argument for
him fighting for the title as well,
for sure.
But that fight was so
controversial and so hyped up.
It would,
I would like to see that fight again.
Matches.
Right.
But don't you think if anyone
deserves to be bluntly,
how long he was just fuck yes.
Right.
But I would say the same
thing about Steve [inaudible].
Steve Bay at Super fucked was
the motherfucker for years.
He's the,
he won more title fight
defenses than any heavyweight
in the history of the sport.
Who sees number one most successful
heavyweight of all time beat nothing but
world champions,
right.
Beat nothing but world
motherfucking champions.
Alistair Overeem,
Fabricio overdoing junior dos Santos,
a Lawsky world,
motherfucking champions and uh,
you know,
and then fights and Gano who's
fucking terrifying beats in Ghana.
Guy Can't get a break.
You didn't get a fight.
Why can't he get a fight?
Because in the cell paper views.
That's crazy.
The only reason the
world's a terrible place
you could do Steve Bay cane.
Ah,
well Keynes going to have to
get another knee surgery now.
Is he for sure how the ways knee went out?
How is it possible you heard
anything about his knee?
I have not.
You don't think it was a knee problem?
Think it was the uppercut
Yardeni update on his name.
I haven't but I haven't asked.
You know,
I could probably try to meet the team,
his ass DC.
His team would have really something
because his team said something really
ridiculous that he didn't get knocked out,
that he got hit behind the head
with an illegal shot first.
How dare you and I love crazy buzz.
Javier.
Javier must been,
maybe you had a few months later on him.
He's a down ass dude and I liked that.
I was like,
but you see a ship full of shit.
He's down for the fresh yet.
Well we were saying we watched
that punch and it didn't even land.
It landed on like the shelter,
the show off the shoulder,
that short sharp.
I just did a food truck diaries on below
the belt with Francis and he showed me
the exact punch cause I was like,
people are saying,
he goes,
he was not happening.
Yeah,
here it is.
Cain Velasquez,
loss of freak.
My knee gave out on me,
but now there was um,
it wasn't him.
It was a Javier Vasquez said,
uh,
it was an illegal punch.
Come on,
see you.
She's got to take the loss back.
You'll have back.
First of all,
it's not an illegal punch when
you're swinging on the feet.
It's illegal on the ground.
If a,
if a guy is swinging and a guy ducks
and you hit him in the back of the head,
there's not a single
referee on the planet earth.
Right?
There's not a single referee in the
planet earth who's ever said that's bad.
Not only that,
a good percentage of head kicks are
illegal shots in the air behind.
There are a lot of Wonderboy shots.
The Wonderboy likes that sneaky question.
Mark kick.
He throws that shit behind the ear.
So it was Barb Rosa.
So does cowboy comes
right over the shoulder.
Wack.
But with gain that
that's not even an issue.
Cause that punch in Atlanta,
the issue is the upper
cut turn the lights off,
which causes need a buckle.
But here's his reno,
he was punched.
If there was a knee problem with this,
with this kind of dilemma about his knee,
his team would have reported
he's going for knee surgery,
there's a MCL,
there's nothing.
They're just like,
uh,
all right,
let's just move on.
So you do steep a camp.
Well Holla at your boy.
She might be in a position where he
doesn't want to have any more knee
surgeries,
but his knees were weak.
Come on for,
no,
but I'm saying if you
got hit with that punch,
maybe in another world like his knee
wouldn't have given out like that.
He would just kinda rocked.
He would've just got rocked.
Maybe.
But him verse Dbas,
the fight,
the good fight.
I'm sure Steve Bay would like it,
but I mean it's what Steve Bay
really wants us another shot at DC,
not I'm in Bro.
Maybe thinks that that's
the way to get to DC.
You would have done it if by now
there's a million reason to do it.
Do you also for DC,
it makes no sense.
He knocked him out so fast.
You can't get any more
impressive than that.
It's kind of like Josie,
Joseph,
Connor.
Yeah.
I fucking starched.
And what do you have
everything to lose now?
Do you want me to do so DC DC's going
to get Brock and probably right off the
sunset,
although Austrian tell
Francis he needs led DC.
Just do his thing.
Dip Out.
He can become the heavyweight champion.
Yeah.
Um,
and DC's looking for
like our big fight in.
That's it.
I mean,
apparently his coaches have already said,
look,
you've got a real legitimate
career as a broadcaster.
And he does.
He's excellent as an analyst or the best.
I love it.
That's the best relationship.
And I'm not throwing shade at Dom.
I love doing it with dom too.
I love doing it with dom.
I bet.
Not as good chemistry.
Well,
you know what it is.
It's a weird dichotomy and I are silly.
We're silly,
not silly.
Dot.
I mean,
dom and I laugh a little,
but he's like Uber serious,
whereas an x,
like when rose no one unit one
and he's yell out thug DC DC's,
he's fun man.
You DC and annex the best commentating
team on the planet and when it's you and
dom,
there seems to be this weird dynamic
where I don't vibe with it really.
I think a lot of people
are on board with that.
That's interesting
because I like it a lot.
Again,
it's not bad,
but it's like UDC and Anik and,
but dom without you,
even with you,
he's amazing.
He's one of the past,
but it's just not as good.
Okay.
I get it.
Um,
it's just,
I agree with his corner though.
I would like to see maybe one
more fight a DC and then look,
he's got his wits about him.
He's got his brains,
he's fine.
He's amazing person.
Like when you hang out
with and talk to him,
he's a sweetheart of a guy the
best and he can talk great.
He spoke very articulately and
as a wrestler unparalleled,
I mean his,
his skill,
his understanding of the
game as a heavyweight,
you can't use the greatest fault.
Auntie Dana just did.
Diddy.
Dan had just made that argument.
He said,
I think the dcs the best of all time.
That's fair.
You can totally make that argument.
He's never lost.
Starched.
Ebay was the best of all time.
Yeah.
But he's only fought once in the UFC and
heavyweight other than this with Frank
Mir.
But dude went out in the strike force.
Yeah.
Grand Prix is insane.
Insane.
Did he fight,
um,
who else did he fight at?
Heavyweight in the UFC.
Did he fight Dom Roy?
He thought Roy Right Ryan that
Roy was in the EOC and Frank Mir.
Yeah,
it'd be both those guys.
Yeah.
It wasn't even a full beat.
The brakes off both of them
and then starch deep bay.
But I think without cutting weight,
he just feels so much better.
That's why if he's gonna Fight John,
we gotta do it.
A heavyweight,
oh,
I know how light heavyweight goes.
Get outta here.
He thinks it was still 100%
you're doing at heavyweight.
What do you think happens at heavyweight?
I think DC has a chance.
Baby.
I'll put my money on because DC,
Kannok bitches out at heavyweight died.
He's the one who can land on John.
Can you get dirty?
Do you think that John
would want that to fight?
Do you think that would be,
that could be like a
giant 4th of July fight.
Bom,
Bom.
Why don't you and I called Dana White
and say we would like to take over the
matchmaker occasionally.
Just we would like like a
celebrity matchup sorta deal.
Let me get my beak where I don't want
to take anything away from McMaster and
Sean Shelby.
Those guys are great,
but just let us,
let us make five fights a year.
Do you hate ratings?
Will help you.
Do you hate money?
Promote the shit out.
Go Bake your posters.
We'll do what we can.
Here's what you do,
Uncle d.
What do we do?
You do DC,
John heavyweight for the world title.
What's the undercard Frances Brock to
really think Brock's going to take that
fight.
Brock wants the title and that's right.
He wants DC DC's almost terrible.
DC's only a little taller than me.
I know.
You know he's a real,
don't let them fool you.
Yeah,
it looks small and like,
like your dad,
you know,
but he'll beat the shit out.
He'll beat the shit out of you.
He's a tank.
He says,
why does a house and you know dude Brock
wants Dude Brock Francis picture the
poster.
Just take that and pictures
of the hospital bill.
Oh,
picture.
Brock's the remaining
years of Brock's life.
I asked Francis of asking,
he got,
he goes,
I don't,
I don't chase.
I chase nobody.
You're not serious.
He flew to,
the funny thing is you standing next to
Francis is almost like me standing next
to you.
He's so damn big.
Oh,
did you?
So we on the curb,
we're on a curb.
I go stand here dude.
You are like huge.
And everyone's going to freak out
on the Internet and he's so big.
He looks huge to 65 natural.
I asked him,
well what do you walk around that?
That's what he said.
And he was 60 65 six.
Did you ask him about
wrestling a little bit,
you know,
with those food truck tires.
I tried to get a little silly
and get those guys to have fun
with Francis.
He talked about how he,
how he kind of felt like
a loser after the steep.
A fight.
Well there's no,
no way around.
It was fastened.
No,
it's fascinating conversation you say
he's saying I kind of felt like a loser
and how he didn't feel like himself and
now he felt pressured to take the fight.
He was not ready.
How well is he like talking
you think I could get him on?
Do you think it would work?
Be Tough.
He's getting better at English though.
Cause when I first interviewed him I
remember way back in the day when I first,
when you had the dreads,
I first interviewed him.
He was having a real hard
time understanding me.
But he's,
he's definitely better at it now.
He's getting better and he,
you know,
yeah.
When he loosens up it'd be
tough to do two hours with you.
Dana White says Daniel Cormier is
getting the Brock Lesnar fight.
Yeah,
but we don't have a
Bronx duals that today.
This post is from an hour ago.
Ooh,
Brock Lesnar folks.
He said at,
at the post fight press conference.
I saw that there's no announcements when
Dee said when core me is fully healed
from his injuries.
Oh he's got an injury.
Yeah,
he's been injured.
What's going on?
Um,
I forget he had a problem with his hand
for the Derrick Lewis fight decided to
take the fight anyway.
And because Steve Bay offered the
fight and that's why he's like,
dude,
I'm injured.
I'm not going to fight you
when I'm injured guys fight.
Derrick Lewis must feel
like shit for steep bay.
He must be like,
God damn it.
You feel bad for Steve Bay?
Yeah.
Cause like if Daniel
Cormay wasn't injured,
he would've got that shot.
Look,
it was hand was okay.
He would have got that shot in New York,
but now Steve Bay's never
going to get that shot.
Dude.
How about John?
Steve,
I feel terror.
Spit balling.
I like gems here,
but I feel,
I feel terrible for Steve Bay to
really do because I mean there's,
how long has it been
since he lost the title?
A year and a hot year.
A year.
How long has it been and
he's tried to fight June
two 26 decent.
My Gosh,
he's from 26 so it wasn't a year.
DC's flat twice.
More than a year.
February,
fuck.
July.
Oh,
what are you talking about?
Do you not know how to count?
No.
That's wrong with you.
I dare you.
I didn't cut,
what'd you say to 26 oh.
Oh,
I thought you were saying that.
You're not 26 I was like,
how dare you,
but still on dare you make that
mistake you will ever see two 26 okay,
well that's July.
So that's not quite a year.
He's been relevant.
He's fought twice since that loss.
Loss of Steve.
He hasn't fought.
It's heartbreaking.
Damn.
Jon Jones,
Steve Bay
coach Javier Mendez can understand
wise TPB Osha is waiting for,
he needs to move on.
It's not happening.
I don't think he necessarily
is waiting for it.
No,
he is.
He even contact it.
He wants it,
but I don't think they're offering
him a valid fight him in the meantime,
I haven't heard any big fights that are,
that are being mentioned.
I mean obviously I could be wrong,
you know.
Well the only,
the only thing they could really
offer him is what is funny.
I have all these questions and
I don't ever call Dana and he,
dude,
come on Bro.
I don't call Sean Shelby and I'll call
them McMahon or I just sit here with you.
We Talk Shit.
We just speculate.
Total stroke,
total speculation.
It was interesting being on it.
Espn for the first time.
That was interesting.
How so?
Different countries doing.
Yeah.
Well look,
I'm holding an ESPN,
a handle on the microphone,
you know,
it was,
it was interesting and
knowing that it's on ESPN,
it's very exciting.
It's very exciting to know that it's on
ESPN now cause I think that's going to
make a big deal with casual fans.
I think it's going to allow the sport
to grow and the ESPN fights were
spectacular.
They put on a good product.
They did it.
What's cool job.
When I turned on ESPN,
I do every morning,
I start my morning is they had a picture
of Bryce Harper who just signed like a
$3 million deal with the
Philadelphia and Jon Jones.
That was the flyer.
Wow.
It's like it's mainstream.
That's giant.
Like Fox could never do that.
No,
no.
Fox was great.
And Fox put the UFC on the map and I
think Fox really did a fantastic job over
those seven years.
But there's a,
it's a big difference.
Going to ESPN is like,
Holy Shit,
we're on ESPN.
It's like Tisdale for sports fields.
Didn't go to any fucking sports part.
ESPN is always on.
So every fight is on and you're
going to have a shit ton of fights.
And if you have ESPN plus you
could watch all the old fights.
You know what?
Bless at the bottom.
Just a scroller say Jon
Jones like breaking news.
Espn inks,
exclusive rights deal with
PFL mixed martial arts league.
Oh,
interesting.
What is a p?
O that's things.
Um,
that's my boy,
Seth is League Thursdays I believe.
I think they have something like
10 events for the year right now.
Okay.
That is excellent.
And they have a player that is excellent.
That is so good for,
for MMA.
It's so good.
10 PFL events in 2019 outstanding.
They do the line across ESPN two,
ESPN,
Deportes daisy and ESPN plus.
Fantastic.
So good.
So good for everybody.
I can't believe Vinny Magalhaes lost.
I was so,
so,
so sure.
He's going to win the whole thing.
I mean,
he's so fucking good man.
And when it comes to the
ground game is like freak.
He's a freak.
He's not a light
heavyweight on the planet.
Esp on also just signed Tyson fury really
interests and now you're not getting
Tyson.
Deontay wilder.
I heard about that.
What the fuck is that about?
What?
What did,
what did Tyson say something crazy
like why would he fight him again?
Um,
when he got robbed of a decision,
the last fight I heard that,
I was like,
is he drinking again?
Dude,
how about this?
How about this?
How about showtime?
My Boys,
they had the trailer,
they had the hype video
ready to launch on Monday.
Tyson signed with ESPN Monday morning.
No one knew.
Nobody fucking knew.
I feel bad for it.
Deontae it's heartbreak bat for deontic
cause Deontae almost put them out in
that final round.
You know?
And I think you can make a
real argument that Tyson one,
the decision for sure,
but when you get dropped twice and
get dropped one time and most horrific
fashion,
I mean,
and now they say the fights not happening.
That's crazy.
It's the biggest problem in boxing.
So angry.
That makes me angry.
That does.
There's different promoters.
That's why the UFC jumped frog
the boxing a long time sorta.
But I mean look,
that fight could have been made.
Do you think that may be Tyson
didn't want to fight him again?
Nope.
I think,
I think it's his,
his handlers is,
is,
is representation.
Go Dude,
let's sign with ESPN.
Get a seven figure deal.
You can fight two bumps and
then we'll circle back to wild.
Well,
may boxing maybe.
I mean there's argument that
that's a good move financially.
I guess.
It's heartbreaking.
Heartbreaking.
Right here.
Oh Dude,
here it is.
I wanted to cry.
I want to cry.
That's sad.
But it does open up Anthony,
Joshua Deontay wilder,
which is very sad.
But yeah,
nothing.
No time soon cause Deontae still gonna
fight and may maybe dealing white maybe
Louis Ortiz.
Yeah.
Lose her t's is still fucking dangerous.
Dealing White's a motherfucker.
Yeah.
So then you know yet
Anthony Joshua be great,
but he's fine.
David Miller.
Yeah.
And that's a tough fight for him.
Big Baby Miller's got some fucking power.
You don't think so?
No.
That's a Madison Square Garden to right.
First Time Anthony.
Joshua was fighting in
the United States though.
Yup.
When you fight in the United
States [inaudible] fuck Tyson fury.
Wow.
Brazil.
That seems like a fake name.
It's like he's a former football player.
Got The dude's name is breeze.
You'd call him Brazil.
Fuck Dominic Brazil boxing's in May.
My mandatory.
So frustrating.
However you got Mikey Garcia.
Earl Spence coming up.
That's amazing.
We should do,
if I can paint for that.
When is that?
March something?
Am I in town?
I don't know.
We should do a final name for boxing.
We don't have any fight
companions for boxing,
right?
Yeah.
Give me an excuse to do.
Hold on.
Sorry.
That's a good one to do it all.
What does it say,
Jamie?
What do we got?
Oh,
Daddy's home.
Daddy's in Miami,
but Miami and profit.
That's my sweet spot of a bitch.
Yeah,
next Saturday.
the fucks it already
March 4th crazy to miss.
This year's flying by January
was looking to see 85 years old.
Before you know it,
we're going to be like Larry
merchant over here talking shit.
Everyone.
Larry Merchant said to Floyd Mayweather,
I was your age.
I'd kick your ass.
Classic fucking class.
Just a ridiculous thing to say.
Greatest boxers of all time.
Oh,
he's fucking such a
crotchety old dude though.
It's going to be us one day.
85 years old.
Calling fights,
getting old.
Just today you think would still
be doing companions oldest?
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
someone's going to drink
themselves to death on a live show.
It's probably going to be Eddie.
I'll have a hard time.
We said we should start
bringing it to other people too.
Occasionally,
especially when a cow is out of town,
cause counts always busy.
Yeah,
but he brings the cheese,
the nothing's like the four of us though.
The chemistry with the finance.
You can't,
you can't fuck with it.
No.
It is the best and it's the most
fun by far is the most fun to watch.
It's a different dynamic,
but the talking over,
my God,
I tried to listen to it.
You did.
I try to listen to someone.
What you do is I want to
know what it sounded like.
We were just talking over everybody.
It's terrible.
I haven't been that drunk and high
and a long time and it was awesome.
People for whatever reason,
love those kind of chaos shows like that.
Alex Jones show the love chaos.
They'll love it.
They'll love a strong and stoned and
an interdimensional child molesters and
fucking,
they love all that shit.
They love it off the charts.
Nuts that Alex Jones one though.
I told you I've,
I've never been a fan of his.
Then I watch it.
I'm like gotta like them now.
People are mad.
Some people are mad at me,
but you know,
there's nothing I can do about that.
There were going to be mad at me anyway,
but one of the things
that they were saying was,
you know,
fuck you for uh,
there were saying giving them a
platform for normalizing him and Mike,
you gotta understand
that's how I know him.
I know him like that.
That's how I know him.
I know that guy,
that guy,
that guy that came on here,
and this is the guy that by the way on
his show said he was gonna kick my ass
and break my legs and fucking all kinds
of crazy shit and I want to find them
the UFC fight.
I'm going to offer him $1 million.
Like I knew,
I knew him.
I know the real him.
I'm like,
well,
we're not in front of each other.
You could say crazy shit.
And like I'm immune man.
I do it.
I don't care.
It doesn't bother me.
I don't care anymore.
He's doing entertainment show.
He is doing entertainment.
But,
but what I know is the Alex Jones,
those here,
and by the way,
he was right about a lot of shit.
A lot of the crazy shit that he was saying
about fucking human pig hybrids that
they're working on those and actually
making human pig hybrid fetuses.
That's real.
They really aren't.
The problem is,
is he throws so much shit
out there all at one time.
I don't know what to
believe in what exactly.
And you got to slow them down to look
into all of that and you've got to go
slow.
Whoa,
whoa.
Let's take start.
Start over again.
What,
what's happening on the moon?
He's for sure little crazy.
I liked him,
but he's,
he's crazy.
But I think the crazy is okay and it's
entertaining and I'm not a fucking child.
So if you want a nerf the world and
make the world so that only children can
watch everybody cause like make,
make things
that are safe for everyone,
including children.
Well,
I don't want that.
I want,
I'm a discerning adults.
I'm pretty rational and I can figure
out what's real and what's nonsense.
Dude.
Speaking of children.
Did you see the Michael Jackson?
I did not,
but I heard it was horrific.
It's crazy.
You don't,
Tim Dillon is so fucking funny.
If you see Tim Dillon snake,
Tim Dillon is pretending that
Michael Jackson was a pimp,
but he was bagging bitches.
Good.
It was good with his Instagram.
If you had Tim on your show,
is that the big guy?
Yeah,
they give the comic.
Yes.
No,
dude,
you got to get him on,
um,
on any times in town and
he's fucking hilarious.
He says,
yeah,
he's a funny dude.
He listen to this.
Listen to,
this is Michael Jackson documentaries.
There's no fucking music in it.
The whole thing is fucking boring.
It's all fucking interviews.
I fast forwarded through all that shit.
I want to see the bitch is the
guys the king of fucking pop.
You know,
he's fucking,
all the time.
He was fucking Elvis's daughter,
Lisa Marie Presley.
You know,
Neverland ranch was just fucking pussy
because they're trying to make him look.
That goes from humanitarian.
Oh,
we help sick kids.
He lets him sleep with them.
We get it.
He was a good guy
and another thing,
so there's this scene.
I was a kind of half listening apparently
some kid walked in on him fucking some
bitch and the kid knows
like every one of his moves,
everything.
He was fucking,
he was like,
what kind of sick kid sneaks into
Michael's room while he's fucking a chick?
It's kind of crazy.
That's the problem with kids.
That's why you can help kids
word to the wise help adults.
It just shits is correct.
It's a ridiculous guy.
Matt,
you got,
you have them on too.
He's very funny.
He's super into conspiracy theories.
Oh is he?
Yeah.
Deep End.
He brought me a book,
so you want to bring you back,
bring it back to the fold,
but he's a smart guy.
Real funny dude.
When he said when he had him on,
he said the comments are brutal.
Shab because someone said,
oh,
why's Rogan haven't Roseanne on again?
You see Roseanne,
she went on Kennesaw and set
up all of the me too girl,
bunch of hose and they were all just
selling sex to try to get successful.
Hilarious.
Rosanna doesn't give a fuck.
Especially now.
They forced her out.
Good,
good.
But they fucked up so hard.
Kicking her out.
That show is number one and
now no one even cares about.
I don't see a market.
They might keep it on just for spite,
just so she couldn't say,
I told you sow,
but we know no one's watching it.
Yeah,
yeah,
you fucked one's watching it.
Yeah.
I don't want to watch that
Michael Jackson thing.
First of all,
it's weird.
Come on that alive.
He's not alive to defend themselves.
It's also stories and you know,
people tell the truth in stories
sometimes and sometimes they don't and you
don't know.
You don't know.
And,
and also there was,
you know,
it was always weird like people,
no one knew why with all the rumors that
everybody had ever heard about Michael
Jackson,
that anybody would let their
kids go and hang out with him.
Like when you watched the documentary,
like these parents are fucking moron.
I don't get it,
man.
Two of the fathers,
I've committed suicide
since this happened.
Oh
Christ.
When we don't have any hard,
oh,
he was molesting kids.
Right.
All we have is rumors.
Well,
here's the thing.
He was acquitted.
Here's the problem.
The doctor,
his very doctor said that
he was chemically castrated.
Him about the guy who killed them.
Yes.
Yeah.
That guy said he was chemically castrated
by his parents to protect his voice.
I have no testosterone.
Right,
exactly.
Not just no testosterone units.
I mean me,
I don't think so.
One or the other weird things
I saw that was like facts.
You should hear it.
No,
from the documentary was that he had,
uh,
some something to do with
the sound in the room.
The hallway leading up to his bedroom was
wired so that footprint's would make a
ding dong sound in the room.
It's just a very strange thing to
just have in general for any purpose.
But if you grow up in the spotlight,
because remember he was such a big star,
you might have anxiety,
right?
Maybe they didn't want
him to be walking in.
I'm a naked or something.
Or you don't want anyone walking
in while you touch in boys.
Could be that.
Look who the fuck we don't know.
We don't know.
However,
what do you think Jamie?
I know,
I'm just saying some of the facts.
I remember he,
he spent like 30 straight nights
with like a 12 year old at his,
at his house in between the kid's Mom's
house in his dad's house and they're
divorce and there's certain
paying for somebody somewhere.
There's so much video of him in
this little boy holding hands.
And the boy in the video goes,
yeah,
we would hold hands and we had a signal,
we'd rub each other's poems when we
were thinking sexually about each other.
However,
you got to chalk it up
to the shitty pants.
Cause if John Legend came to my house,
it was like,
dude,
I love tiger.
You mind if I take him
out for a little while?
But yet your God damn mind
you're not going anywhere.
A lot of that.
And John Legend's,
not a pedophile,
I'm just not known.
But they didn't know Michael Jackson
was that everybody knew there was
something.
I'm not at the time he was the biggest
star in the world back then in the iron
man.
People in the nineties yes.
Yes.
Good music.
You fuck
everybody knew something was really I did.
And he was always telling my kids.
Yeah cause he loved Neil Young.
Younger than us.
Wait,
you got to trust me.
I knew something was up that Jamie's more
on the ball then you saw he was always
online.
You're out getting pussy.
James Online
looked at well,
well played Sir.
Well played.
I just feel like it's too weird.
It's too weird to let your kids
hang out with this grown man.
All those times.
I,
he was mentally ill.
They and what his family says,
they go,
no,
no.
A lot of you are confusing him for being,
he didn't have a childhood.
His Dad,
Robert with his child.
So inside he felt like
he was nine years old.
So he missed out on the
sleepovers and video games.
So he would get friends with kids.
And I think
it's batshit crazy,
batshit crazy.
I think all those things
that you're saying are true,
but I also think it's true that he
was probably chemically castrated.
I really think that's true because
I've said that a long time ago.
I said,
I think he's a cast.
Trato the waste,
his voice is hah,
hah.
Tell them that it's human nature.
It's just that voice is
just not a man's voice.
She was not even a falsetto.
Yep.
A woman's voice.
Castrated.
Then when he would have zero
testosterone nonetheless,
kits,
well,
he might not have been doing
it because he was horny.
It might've been doing it
because he was just weird.
Well,
these kits as he was busted nuts,
the kids in the video said like you
would jack himself off in front of them.
Boy,
it,
it'll make you sick to your
stomach is not his wife,
but the woman that gave birth to his
two kids said she'd never had sex with
them.
Yeah,
that's more likely.
If you're chemically castrated,
that means your body doesn't
produce any testosterone anymore,
but it doesn't mean you can't shoot
it into your body and you know,
you could shoot test into your body,
but if you have no net not,
you're not making seaman.
Yeah,
have your balls are dead,
but you isn't semen or sperm sperm from
the nuts and then like your prostate and
I said are the things that
get the juice together,
not a doctor.
Clearly
the whole thing is fucking super weird.
It's weird.
It just makes me sad.
It makes me so sad,
but there's like a,
there's a,
there's a lesson to be learned
there in so many different ways,
but one of the big lessons to be learned
is that you never want to be that
famous that that was my takeaway.
I W I W I was watching my grind.
I go,
can you imagine being that famous?
And she goes,
yeah,
I was probably awesome.
No,
hold on.
You know how we like to go to the mall?
We like go out to eat.
That's gone.
You can't do that anymore.
That's all gone.
It's all gone.
People would book,
but they'll start a riot.
But take that,
take that away from your
normal life is not over.
You just stay in your house.
But yeah,
that's why he developed an amusement park.
Like he made his house,
I'll fucking amusement park.
They had,
they set this up for him
to go grocery shopping.
They had a fake the empty at a grocery
store and paid people to be a shoppers so
he could have the experience
of what it's like to be normal.
They're like a Ralph's or whatever.
Yeah.
Like,
hey,
how's it going?
Jesus,
this is,
well,
they should make everything.
So he hired people to do that,
but,
and he wore a hat and
he's dancing around that.
It's so weird.
Everything was weird,
man.
Everything was bad form though.
Oh yeah.
So we know how much he's worth.
I Dunno.
One point $7 billion,
they say,
but that's after he died.
It see,
the thing is when he died,
he got super rich.
He was actually in the
hole before he died.
No.
Because there's,
because it wasn't tour hammer broke
where when he talked to Mc Hammer,
he's like,
what are you talking about?
He's like,
there's like,
you know,
publicists broke where they
released that you go bankrupt.
And so it was fun.
I was balling.
Hmm.
I think it was Michael Jackson.
He owned the Beatles catalog.
Oh.
So that's where he had all his money.
He bought all the originals.
The masters of his and the beat.
Yeah.
Paul Mccartney was mad about
that apparent when he told him.
He gave me the idea.
Paul gave me idea.
Good idea.
Oh,
I'll be right back.
So why Paul by it,
he's got money.
You can afford it.
Here's one fourth of the Beatles money.
Not all of it combining to take help you.
There's no stars like Michael Jackson.
You can't write,
can't do anything.
Current society,
there's,
there's pockets now you
also in happy birthday,
he owned happy birthday.
He bought the rights to it.
So that's why you weren't,
you're not allowed to sing
in a restaurant that's over.
I think you can say it now cause
it's back into the public domain.
That's why everyone syncs the bullshit.
Happy Birthday.
Happy,
happy birthday.
happy,
happy thing like ASCAP or Bmi could
literally come in and just find the
restaurant.
If you were sitting in that
shit cause I'm Michael.
That's so stupid.
Dude.
Water ball or move with a copywriter.
Happy Birthday money.
Too bad he doesn't like bitches cause
that'd be the biggest movie ever.
Maybe did like I who knows?
Well the guy's dead.
He can't the Fafsa on the SPEC shop.
Here's the thing,
those two dudes who are doing it,
they were one was the key witness
when he got away in court.
What dudes?
The dudes in the documentary,
the two we got molested.
The one was the number one key witness
who was saying he didn't get them listed.
Okay,
well then now you shouldn't
be able to say anything.
Both of them were with cause that means
they should go to jail and now they're
like well no that's not true.
We were young bitch you are 12
well also like isn't that perjury?
It means he lied in court.
Be fucked.
You can't lie in court either way.
One way or the other.
You can't lie to protect somebody and
you can't lie to accuse someone either.
You can't lie.
I don't know what the deal is that,
I mean,
that seems like that's something they
could drag him to court for it and the
Jackson came out,
went,
well,
isn't it convenient you guys are
coming out now when you're in financial
trouble?
Uh,
of course.
Yeah,
It just seems like a strange thing to do.
A documentary on documentaries
are killing it lately.
That's Kelly.
He thought he was flying free.
Missing on pitches.
Isn't that documentary came out.
He's fucked.
Yeah.
He's fun.
Arrested.
Yeah.
They just released him.
Did you see when they released him,
like he,
he leaves jail and he has to walk
through a throng of people and there was
Scranton.
Some of the woman was yelling at him,
calling him.
They took his music off iTunes.
Really?
They took down all of the shit and all
the artists who worked with them took
their music down.
Like let's say,
let's say Michael Jackson did
get convicted of molesting kids.
Could you still listen to his music?
Could you imagine you separate,
right.
Do you know Tony Hinchcliffe?
I don't want to give away the bit.
He has a fucking hilarious bit about that.
He has a hilarious bit about really,
I bet he's redoing it now because I don't
think it's on the special on his last
special.
I don't think it's on so no,
I heard it.
Yeah.
Dude.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
He's got some fucking,
he's got this new bit
about transgender athletes.
What does it say?
Their daycare affiliated woman who
bailed R Kelly out of jail receives bomb
threat.
It's a mystery woman bailed him out.
He's looking like shit.
It's been stressful time.
Fuck yeah.
We're going to so uh,
upcoming fights.
Let's get back to MMA for a few minutes
where we get the fuck out of here at
jds.
Derrick Lewis to Kelvin.
Kelvin Israel at a sign.
Yeah.
That's what I want to see.
That's next month son.
That's next month.
And that is in mother fucking Atlanta,
Georgia.
Is that a paper view?
Yes it is,
sir.
You're gone do Holloway pour.
Yay Too.
I'll be there for that one.
Holloway port A's up.
Great fight.
It is a good fight,
but stolen.
And who won the first fight?
Holloway Holloway One,
right?
It was a decision.
Pretty sure.
Yeah.
Just scroll up.
Let me see what else is on that card.
Ovn St Peru and Nikita cry love us
right in the kidneys for a heavyweight.
Now he's a lighter Kaleel
Roundtree Jr Eric Anders.
Woo.
That's a good fight.
Great.
But that's,
that's under the radar fight.
Montel Jackson,
you know,
a Johnny Walker knocked out cold
Roundtree to tea with elbows,
food from the clench and
[inaudible] serious striker,
Wilson Hayes Alhondo punt.
A little fact about
Cleo Roundtree you know,
used to be over 300 pounds.
Really used to be fat as fuck.
That's crazy because he
doesn't have any loose skin.
I know some guys,
they bounce down.
Good.
He's young and he was working
in the MMA fucking warehouse.
Well that's the same
thing with David Goggins.
David Goggins,
the uh,
oh maybe CBCL he bounced back to Whoa,
look at him.
10 years,
2010 and 2016 that's only six years.
Six years challenge.
She imagine you break up with him
and six years later he's jacked dude,
dime piece.
Look at that boy.
Now I'm just tired of you being off fat
getting on top of me and I can't preach.
It's over.
Kaleel now he's like,
what's up bitch?
Six years later,
big fat dick still dude knocked out.
Go Con Saki with one punch.
He's a beast.
God Damn.
It just shows you like how crazy
powerful Johnnie Walker is,
man.
It's ridiculous.
Ridiculously proud he'd do with him next.
Yeah,
take it slow.
Giving them good fights.
Don't kill him.
Don't give him a fee.
No,
no.
The TV pisses me off.
Does he watch so good and he,
he,
you know he's not he Tory Anderson,
man.
Nobody's given Cory Anderson any love.
How weird is that?
I know,
it's weird.
You know,
and,
and a lot of people say it's
because he's not stopping people.
He's just winning.
He's buddies with point fucking beat.
He beat Latifi see you're talking about
Latifi and not talking about Corey
Anderson.
You know,
it's here.
It's a lot more apps.
And Corey were,
sorry Corey,
we're sorry,
but fuck the core is a bow hunter to yep.
That must be fun,
but fuck that.
How bout,
how bout um,
Jimmy Manawan Johnnie Walker?
Uh,
there's another one on the house.
Dana White.
Well,
that doubt is a possibility.
Yeah.
Jimmy man was dangerous,
but no,
so it was Johnny Walker.
Serious power to me,
man.
All it's great.
That fight with Tiago Santos was
chaos for as long as it lasts.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Johnny Walker,
Jimmy Manoa.
Sign me the fuck up.
Ooh.
You know the brain busters.
How do you feel like a Dustin
poray Max Holloway plays out
next.
Always.
So God damn talented.
So I'm not having to cut out 45 anymore.
It's tough.
Fight for Dustin.
Dustin,
you know,
I love you.
I'm glad Dustin got a big fight.
[inaudible] super.
What's interesting is
they offered the fight.
Tony Ferguson turned it down,
but here about this Dustin
Poirier AA stops pedis.
Right?
Did he stop pedis?
Um,
he stopped Justin Kgg.
Who else did he stop?
That was his last flight.
Right?
Those two.
But those are two world champions.
There was another one.
There was another fight in there
or he stopped somebody else.
Totally different animal.
Who else did he stopped?
He stopped someone else.
It's
Alvarez.
Eddie Alvarez.
Chasse fight.
Yeah.
I mean those are three
legitimate champions.
I mean,
I know.
Just engage you with the champion
and the PFL before it was a Pfl.
Right.
What would they call it back then?
World series of fighting.
Yeah.
So he,
when he beat him,
he beat Pettis.
He beat Eddie Alvarez and this is,
this is that light heavyweight jump,
you know?
And you also beat Jim Miller.
I mean,
Damn.
His last fight was a
at 45 against Michael.
Where's that?
At?
55 55 it might have been
55 with Michael Johnson.
That was before Johnson went to 45
Johnson at 45 some mother fucker.
He's a motherfucker.
Yeah,
I mean I'm,
I'm really excited about that.
To fight.
And he got it.
Yeah.
He's got an interim title idea.
Why Tony Ferguson turned it down.
I do not.
No,
I have not talked to Tony Ferguson
mean maybe it was because,
hey,
I already am the fucking
interim title holder.
Why would I fight for
the interim title again?
Max Holloway though.
Yeah,
I get that.
But I mean he already was the interim
title holder and then they just took it
away from him when he was doing crap.
I think it's really fucked up.
Really comes back and beats pedis.
Here's what's fucked up
is now the winter Max.
All he doesn't he he's
guaranteed a title shot.
Yeah.
So Tony still not going to get a shot.
Yeah,
they were trying to do cowboy
versus Connor and apparently the,
the sticking point was that it
was going to be a co main event.
How dare they,
I think the idea is that they
have to have world titles as a,
as a main event.
So paper,
Ooh,
that's my west DW.
Get your head out of your ass.
You got us.
Shoot him a text.
I don't have stuff similar.
Hard selling hard.
Did he block too?
I think so.
When I seen that shit,
I actually liked the
guy who had no problems.
I know.
I tried to get you guys together.
I gave it my best shot.
I gave him my fucking,
you tried man.
Sometimes she's got an eye level.
Yeah,
I don't understand it man.
It's weird when you have friends
that don't like each other,
you know when you're good friends with
both of them and they're like fuck that
guy.
And he's like,
all right,
well I don't want to tell you but I don't,
I don't talk bad about it.
No you don't.
I criticize some Yossi decisions cause I
do a show but then I have no issue with
the metal.
I like that though.
I mean look,
part of the thrill of these things,
it's gotta be region owl.
Cowboy was in my office yesterday,
you know him white said he wants
a Pfizer ready to it again.
What's fight against silicon?
Another opponent for him,
maybe raging now it does not specify
who's throwing to be fighting next.
So it says,
dude,
you're telling me Connor was like,
no,
I'm not taking the final
foam co main event.
Why in the fuck would you make that a
company could be out of action until the
fall.
Mcgregor could be,
you know,
the other things.
But Gregor has a fun so
long that he has a fight.
MMS So long.
Good.
That's fine.
We can,
his last fight was Khabib.
Right?
But he takes like almost to two years off.
He fights Khabib.
He gets smoked by Khabib and then he has,
how long was that?
How was that?
November was a long time off.
It's not good.
No,
it needs to be active,
like really act.
It's hard to be active when
you're making that much money off.
That's the problem.
The whiskey,
the whiskey and it need like a hundred
million dollars off the Floyd Mayweather
fight he's making but bup,
bup,
buying whiskey.
I'm proud of him.
He's doing great.
Tight look between you and him.
I mean him while he's in the middle
of his career and you post career,
I mean you've guys have laid some
interesting blueprints for fighters.
So yeah.
The um,
it was October,
October,
2018.
That's quite a lot long time ago.
That's not good if it's not that far.
November,
December,
January,
February.
I was like five months ago.
It seems like a long time ago.
That doesn't it.
But he has nothing coming up so nothing.
I'm,
he fights with me another year.
That was his last fight and it was two
years before that was his previous fight.
Yeah,
it's not good.
It's not good.
Especially if you want
to be Creme de la creme,
you just can't fight like that.
I think he's only
interested in big fights,
like things that excite him now.
You know,
because he's got so much
money and so much success.
It's just one of those things.
Can you blame them?
But here,
look at that,
that main event,
the main event of that
fight was a non title fight.
Conor verses Nate Diaz that was non title.
Both times they fought
and but the last one,
the,
the fact that it was a non title fight,
it was also the biggest
paper view of all time.
Dude.
Whoever recommended that he be
coming event against Galbally,
she kept their mouth's piston.
That's
so aggressive.
That's why Dana does it like,
well,
I don't know who that was,
but
I'm just saying to say that I
disagree with your decision.
I believe I can fly.
All right,
let's wrap this up for
your voice goes out.
We did it,
dude.
There's no way I'm doing standup tonight.
No,
apologize to everyone.
Yeah,
you can't.
Well,
everybody who listens to this podcast
will know you're not faking it.
They're going to be pissed,
Eh,
we're going to do,
you're the store tonight for this
recipe on the store tomorrow night.
It's a stack show.
I'll be back tomorrow night to my,
you're good.
Next week.
I'm back on tour in Miami Friday.
Saturday.
What'd he do off?
Oh,
Miami Improv.
That's next week.
Then after that,
I'm in Milwaukee,
Turner Hall.
After that,
I'm in Washington,
DC,
DC.
Improv T.
Dot.
k.com.
Woo.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow the more goodness.
See Ya.
Bye.